the jurogan experience
i think we have to accept on both sides
of this combat sport equation that these
are different disciplines it's not uh it
doesn't make you a lesser mma fighter
because
an average boxer can beat you and vice
versa right and now if you want to come
up with some hybrid sport i mean i've
seen people try it i saw something like
in the round and i've seen different
promoters try to come up with some
hybrid but until one of those things
becomes a thing
these are just apples and oranges
you know it'll be the craziest [ __ ] of
all time the craziest [ __ ] of all time
if tyson fiore says
i'm just gonna take a couple years off
and i'm gonna learn mma and i'm gonna
come back i'm gonna be the mma
heavyweight champion of the world i'm
gonna [ __ ] everybody up
uh well i'll tell you this the first
fight
you won't find a place big enough won't
find a place big enough there won't be a
second fight you'll have to have the
first
you'll have to have the first fight on
earth it would just be destination earth
everyone is going to want to climb
tell me where it's stonehenge
we would all go
yeah but i think that
that would be uh is in terms of what
people be interested in that would be
massive yeah but i think with francis
and donald's first leg kick you'd be
like oh no yeah that's my point oh no
what have i done the interest exists but
the payoff is is not going to be nearly
worth the ticket price it's gonna be the
obvious his fight against dylan white
was
magical
it was magical yeah yeah i interesting
it's interesting to see a guy like that
big that tall
you know that is uh in his prime
you know and and just deciding he's
gonna step away which i don't buy for a
[ __ ] hot second
i don't believe that he could resist
the opportunity
to fight undisputed and then really
retire as undisputed undefeated
heavyweight champion of the world if
that is presented to him as an option
and he truly believes that he can beat
any heavyweight in the game including
the title holders at the current time so
whoever ends up with all the other belts
except the wbc i'm certain
king's coming
up he can beat that person yeah him
passing on that opportunity i don't see
it happening he's too competitive a guy
it's too big a fight and the the
seduction of being able to be that one
guy that ever did that
he can't pass it up i have a theory and
this is not my own theory either this is
a theory that somebody labeled at me
threw it at me i wish i could remember
who told me this but i think it's right
they said now he made his intentions
known after the fight he brings over
francis and gano and says we're gonna
have a hybrid fight with uh these four
ounce gloves on that doesn't sound like
boxing to me it sounds like a hybrid
fight what do i need all these [ __ ]
boxing commissions and i'll i wouldn't
do the wbc and everybody's gonna get
their piece the [ __ ] out of here with
your piece i quit
i retire have someone fight for this
[ __ ] title that you know is mine
you know it's mine immediately his
[ __ ] title right right so what are
you gonna do you take it away and give
it to somebody else everyone's gonna
know tyson fury's still around but he
just retired so he doesn't have to pay
you he doesn't have to pay the wba or
wbc or whoever the [ __ ] has the the
title reigns and to your point he made
that exact case when he came back the
last time he was like you know no one's
ever beaten me i'm still a lineal
champion yes i'm still the guy to beat
and thus far that has remained true no
one has yet beaten him so if you put on
those little gloves i'm telling you it's
going to be an incredible promotion i'll
be front row i'll hopefully be sitting
right next to you but there is no way
that inganu wins that fight if it's just
boxing he's gonna have a really hard
time hitting him the smaller the gloves
the more trouble he's in this guy is a
gypsy king yeah he are you kidding me
he'd just do hand wraps if you let him
yeah and it's only going to make it
harder for a gunner to stay awake
i want to see the fight don't let me
[ __ ] it up but i'm trying to tell you
this guy's in a lot of trouble
and ghana does have the nuclear option
though he really does he does have
nuclear one-punch knockout power he has
uh one of his knockouts of alistar over
him was one of the most terrifying
knockouts i've ever seen in my life he
spun alistar's head behind he was
looking at the back of his feet
that's how hard he hit him now is he
going to land that on tyson fury it's
going to be real [ __ ] hard but the
problem is what kind of hybrid rules are
we talking about are we allowed to
clinch because we're allowed to clench
tyson's in a lot of trouble because if
if francis can clinch you
and could hold on to you and just punch
you in the face in in in a way that's
illegal in boxing watch this again
okay that is very impressive he does
that to everybody he does everybody the
thing is oh it's what's terrible from
the hip yeah like yeah that's a that's a
will smith punch man
[Music]
it's terrible technique in that regard
but he was doing it because he knew the
opening was there he was just winging it
um that's not
going to work that way on tyson fury
absolutely no chance but he's not going
to fight that way on tyson fury either
he's fighting that way on alistair
because he knows that alistair is
you know he's not in his prime he's just
gonna just smash him he's trying to make
his
statement of being the top heavyweight
contender in the ufc at the time when he
knocked him out
i
you know last ones here i think what are
we talking about pacquiao uh
conor mcgregor maybe we were talking
about some other
uh mm-hmm they were talking about that
yeah we were right
they were talking about doing that for a
while yeah and i was like i don't want
to see it like i'm going on record right
now like i have no interest in that i
want to see it
small little mma gloves and these two
behemoths
[Laughter]
i want to see it but not because it's
competitive but because that's how much
a sucker i am for a heavyweight knockout
yeah but that's it's even if it's not
competitive i want to see it be
uncompetitive i want to see tyson fewer
pitch a shutout i want to see him
lighten them up i want to see the world
i want the world to see what it's like
when the best [ __ ] on earth it
at his given thing gets to express
himself with someone who's trying it out
full-blown destruction is what happens i
don't unless they allow clinching okay
but they don't have to allow it in
boxing technically you're not allowed to
hold that's you know but if you could
hold and hit because you can in mma it's
called dirty boxing guys grab the back
your head and smash your knees oh you
mean like i mean hold on to you keep you
in place see that's what i'm saying if
that's that's filed for that yeah but
that's not in a hybrid rule situation
with mma gloves if francis inganu gets
tyson fury to agree to let him hold it
hit
like you could put a guy in a headlock
and just 100 oh yeah no yeah see that's
what i'm saying okay if you could hold
on to a guy if you could just get an
overhook yeah just completely tie up
that arm and just smash him in the face
if you could tie the get him in a collar
tie when you're holding the back of his
neck and you're smashing him in the face
that's legal in mma that happens all the
time i would say the closest uh you know
ironically the closest i've seen that in
boxing was pretty
effective and not entirely illegal uh
wide have been klitschko fury like you
don't forget that was a very clinch
heavy fight yeah siri was able to make
the fight dirty boxing and child made
everything clinch heavy jab clinch jab
right hand clinch but only fury was able
to turn that against him yes so even in
this scenario i get okay that gives
ingano a much better chance because
that's something he's skilled at yeah
but tyson is not unskilled at that
that's how he won all those belts in the
first place right true and you know
being the gypsy king like those
those bare-knuckle travelers are known
for having fights bare-knuckle that's
the whole thing they have a [ __ ]
whole culture behind it they have bare
knuckle fighting and gypsies goes back
forever that's what i'm saying he's he's
he's like you know i'm sure he's had
fans
don't throw me in that briar pack
smaller gloves oh no
[Laughter]
i would love to see it no matter what
and i love francis angano so i'd like
him to get a giant payday and i think it
would be an enormous payday oh huge huge
it would be spectacular francis ingano
versus
the gypsy king for the undisputed
baddest man on the planet
oh my god it'd be so much money
that's what i want for francis i want
and if it's little gloves man you can't
[ __ ] around with little gloves